this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armories Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this week's episode Jonathan is taking a
look at the Ultimate Universe historical
Weaponry of Foxhole with of course A
Little Help From The Game's Community
regiment here at the front of the line
I'm completely distracted by the black
and white apparently old-timey War
correspondent there that's genius if
there are any other games going to
mechanics do you guys want to see
Jonathan breakdown let us know in the
comment section below and for something
a little bit different make sure to
check out our new series Mind Games a
show that explores the psychological
impact of gaming from a relationship
with loot boxes to the psychology behind
horror games thank you again to everyone
in the Foxhall Community who submitted
Clips to show off some of the game but
without further Ado time to check out
the guns of Foxhole
foreign
Ty now this is a apparent and apparently
self-loading rifle we've got some
somewhat fudged loading animation where
we're sort of it's got an extended box
Magazine on it but we're loading it from
the top as we know that's something that
was done historically up to maybe the
1950s depending on what the weapon was
the rifle itself has a very long spindly
looking cocking handle on it too spindly
I would say now that having a big long
sticky out cocking handle with a knob on
it is not as unusual as you might think
for a self-loading rifle case in point
for
sticky out cocking handle with a with a
large knob on it this is the che rigotti
an Italian self-loading rifle very rare
very important given the name of this
thing argenti rigati the pseudo Italian
nature of I think this faction if anyone
like me doesn't know the game clearly
this is an alternate reality with
fictional Nations and it gives them the
freedom to come up with whole whole new
set of weapons and equipment and
everything else which is which is a way
to preface me saying that actually it's
not that close to the actual Che regotti
the overall silhouette is not far off
the front end is is somewhat reminiscent
but it's not it's by no means slavishly
copied in fact I'd say it's pretty far
off in some ways nonetheless I think
this this definitely fits the vibe of
the alternate reality never-ending War
scenario that we have here because I'm
seeing hints of first and second world
war in the general style of this game
foreign
will forgive me a worms version of a
boy's anti-tank rifle I probably lean
more boys but then it is a bit l39 latte
as well 20 millimeter anti-tank so yeah
I'd say probably a mashup of those two
um that sort of knuckle bow trigger
guard thing I think is is not something
that either of those ever had in keeping
with reality it doesn't look like it's
capable of knocking out a tank well not
without many shots anyway it's my
initial impression and then a couple of
shots to take out a lighter vehicle it's
probably about right depends very much
on the distance the type of vehicle
where you happen to hit it a single
Boy's Round through an engine block
would disable or into an engine block I
should say not through would disable a
lot of vehicles but it might not if it
doesn't hit the right thing although
this is not this is not making any great
pretense at photo real listen or
anything like that and clearly the
weapons are somewhat abstracted and
stuff the heft that the I guess the
player character has that showing you
know this is a big heavy thing and I'm
having to apply effort to remove the
magazine that conveys more weight and
realism than a lot of first-person
shooters do with this absolutely perfect
representations of the actual weapon you
can be quote unquote realistic in
different ways and and I got that
impression from just from that clip
even more intrigued by that bit of
gameplay there so the weapon itself
probably maybe a somewhat of a mashup of
the the Lewis gun and the Vickers Geo
gas operated the Vicars K gun but it is
definitely in the ground roll set up as
a light machine gun I'm more interested
in how it's being employed there if
somebody is posted up in the prone
firing bursts more importantly what
they're doing what they appear to
successfully be doing there is
suppressing suppression systems they
either either non-existent or they don't
work very well and of course in real
life a bullet passing near you over your
head cracking past your ear if it's
supersonic or thumping into the ground
all of those things make you reconsider
Your Life Choices as a competent of
whatever kind and that's something
that's very hard to actually pull off in
a game you're left with an impression of
a game that doesn't deal in realism in
detail because it's taken an abstract
art style and an alternate reality
setting and some artistic license but
that has a lot of potential for feeling
like you're in a real first half of the
20th century battle even if you're not
able to to truly represent that and who
is you know no game can can truly
represent that
foreign
another rifle to look at now lots of
different inspiration here we've got a
very Schmidt Reuben style cocking handle
there this is the French mass 44. now
the main difference here is this is very
s this is quite quite slim but quite
squared off this thing has more of a
tubular receiver but even even the shape
of the magazine design of the magazine
is not too far off on this admittedly
this has the magazine catch built into
the mag which is weird and you can see
the stock configuration very reminiscent
of what they've gone for uh here but
that particular shape is I think
definitely a cue as is the the
semi-pistol grip stock which is again
not Universal on rifles at the time and
the configuration with this bayonet
tube under the barrel where the bayonet
locks in now that's not present but
there is a hint of a of a second tube
underneath we've only got uh one barrel
band on the reel on this real thing
about our Barrel band and a nose cap
this gun has two barrel bands and no
nose cap relatively close and actually
just a really cool historic rifle to to
have an excuse to to get out and
briefly talk about
come across the Armco regiment here at
the front of the line as mortars there's
motor action prepares to try and wear
down the warden line wow what a
fascinating game that I've been
completely distracted by the black and
white apparently old-timey voice forgive
me if that's your real voice so but um
War correspondent there that's genius I
love the idea of somebody joining a
server just to report on the war as it's
going on now I have I have been made
aware this is a persistent multiplayer
online War that's going on so I do I
understand a little bit of the context
there but I've never literally never
seen that done before now the actual
mortar gameplay there so we've got
people working together both multiple
mortiman but also someone with a pair of
binoculars that seems to be facilitating
how they're able to see what the hell's
going on all very good and quote unquote
realistic um the only thing that I'm not
a not a tactician or anything but all
rather bunch up and we saw some counter
battery fire there where they got
clobbered from by the enemy firing back
at them and they all would have taken
damage presumably from that hit whereas
if they'd been more spaced out and
coordinating on a single point of aim
that would seem to me to be better but
multiple clips of guys bunching up and
spamming mortars so I'm guessing that's
advantageous in the game rather than
spreading out which may or may not speak
to how realistic things are currently
I think
[Applause]
come on yeah good job good job fall back
all right an interesting anti-tank
weapon there not not bang on but um more
reminiscent of something like the rpg2
which is what I have here very much a
metal tube with a wooden heat shield but
it's an interesting choice because well
this is definitively post-war being
worked on in the 1940s but it's not not
in production until the 50s the rpg-2
and then with only a decade or so
superseded by the much more famous and
more capable rpg7 but I suppose
superficially the technology level of it
it feels plausible to be in this game we
have things like the Bazooka the panda
Shrek in the second world war so if this
appears later on in in a game then yeah
why not
right this one threw me um for for
several minutes there because I was
racking my brains to think what it could
be size and proportions may be of a
heavier machine gun but I think it's
it's got a dollar bipod it's meant to be
a light machine gun the drum magazines
on the side not very common at all
um there are a couple of designs that do
it what they must have based this on
though is the the ribel
m1931 designation uh it's a French
French machine gun intended I believe
for armored vehicles and fortifications
not for this kind of infantry use but
for all I know it was adapted with a
ground kit so if you have a look at look
at that it's got the same curved butt
stock tubular strut vaguely similar
silhouette and especially that single
rotating drum magazine on the side very
distinctive curved reverse curve pistol
grip because it's there to allow you to
if necessary
fire down using the bottom part of the
pistol grip or via level by holding the
upper part so clearly the game is taking
some not not the first one we've seen
but some real life inspiration and a lot
of license as well
strong strong impression here from the
3D model of a mashup of a Thompson and a
publisher so the two submachine guns
whereas in fact in the game this thing's
functioning as a rifle it's it's got
visible recoil more so than either of
those SMGs would have I happen to have a
Thompson floating around here there's a
model 1928 don't have the drum on this
one but um otherwise it's not you know
the back end is very reminiscent of what
we just saw there but it does have that
sort of heat shield Arrangement and drum
obviously this case is capable of taking
a drum as well but the two together make
me feel like it's a sort of cut and shut
of those two guns but the thing itself
is a rifle firing a larger more powerful
cartridge now both both types of both
classes of weapon superb for what you
might call clearing a trench and what
I've Just Seen there is a clip of a guy
doing just that jumping into a trench
and taking a group of enemy Soldiers by
surprise and using surprise and weight
of fire taking them all out and that's
what both of those weapon classes are
very good at so this is almost what what
might have happened if Thompson had gone
back to the drawing board on the
automatic rifle that he worked on at one
time and came up with a sort of diesel
Punk take on that still with a drum on
it but firing a rifle cartridge and then
at some point someone to come up with
the intermediate caliber concept as well
but we're working with alternate history
here so
good work all right well this if I had
to try to pick a weapon from this game
that I've seen so far that has a very
clear unequivocal inspiration it would
have to be this one because this thing
is a and I don't mean this in any
disparaging way a cartoon MP40 it's a it
has a sort of caricature proportions of
this thing the design of the butt stock
the way the pistol grip lower receive
everything is is set up the magazine
housing the barrel sticking out on its
own like that without it without a
shield or a shroud on it and actually
the way it's depicted in use as well
somewhat steady slow-ish rate of fire
appeared to keep most of its bullets in
a line top down which is what what you
want and this thing does that this thing
stays pretty much where you put it and
just chugs away so it's it's like you
know I've heard people describe it as
like like shooting a sewing machine if
that makes sense just chugs away putting
holes where holes need to go very hard
to deny that inspiration that that and
what it's alluding to whereas other guns
in the game are more mashups or they are
more original
thanks man
okay this is a fascinating game so my
first impression was wow that's big it's
like a 50 caliber machine gun an early
water cooled one and then I see the the
in-game menu and it's 12.7 ammunition
which is indeed 50 caliber or in that
class this is a true heavy machine gun
now on the one hand well a heavy machine
by modern standards I should say so
that's that's somewhat anachronistic for
our version of this Myriad of History
because these were not infantry guns
these were guns for mounting on tanks
for putting on some aircraft these
things are were deemed too big and heavy
to be moved even with it with a team of
six like like a Vicar's gun would be
moved now uh in terms of the actual
deployments of it really nice to see you
have to work as a team you can carry
that big gun around all day long but if
the guy with a tripod doesn't go and
stick that somewhere for you to put the
gun on ideally not in an exposed
location where you're going to get shot
you can not use that gun now the teams
that existed were actually you know more
than two guys you needed at least the
very least three one with the gun one
with the tripod one with some ammunition
and that would be Bare Bones to actually
efficiently run a machine gun but this
is a major elite forward compared to
just about every game I've ever seen in
terms of how it represents the medium
slash heavy machine gun
all right so now anything with a rifle
caliber magazine on the side people are
going to think fg42 this is called a
storm rifle storm rifle the literal
translation of storm cover usually
translated as an assault rifle Loosely
connected to the name and a magazine on
the side and it being rifle caliber you
might think fg42 however what this looks
the most like to me receiver Wise It's a
little bit reminiscent of a stun
especially this Mark 5 with its wooden
butt stock and pistol grip although this
gun has those combined into a single
unit that's not very common usually it's
either a stock with no pistol grip or
it's a separate pistol grip as on this
Mark 5 stand but it's hard to argue I
think with this reinforcing ring the
tubular receiver and the little sight on
the rear the stand also has a magazine
on the side albeit the other side albeit
pistol caliber and then it does drop
down to a sort of the barrel obviously
at the front end the resemblance kind of
ends there to be fair so this is this is
it's very much its own thing at least a
couple of design cues there you could
probably spot others that I'm not
thinking of but it's it's I would call
this an original design
all right this is really quite out there
by the game's own standards I would
suggest an octagonal Barrel no a
hexagonal Barrel not not unheard or in
Firearms but very uncommon in the
self-loading slash automatic era that
we're very much in this game the
Magazine's sticking being straight but
sticking out to the front like that is a
bit curious there are a couple of
submachine guns that end up looking like
they have a magazine sticking out
jutting out forwards and ump tends to
give that impression but not not to this
extent the only thing on this that jumps
out to me is being real world inspired
is the pistol grip which looks an awful
lot like it's based on the AK M plastic
pistol grip the butt stock is very
flimsy looking I wouldn't trust that if
this was a real gun it looks it looks a
bit over engineered very lots of very
straight lines unusual looking thing
yeah really curious ready three two one
and send it
I keep showing don't stop
wow that was that was seriously
impressive I saw the the model for this
uh big artillery piece and I thought I
was going to see one of those in action
and only to see a ton of them as a
coordinated his artillery battery uh
that's got to be the most impressive
video game artillery thing I've ever
seen not that artillery is really very
front and center in most games to do it
any sort of justice is is very difficult
this is probably the closest anyone's
come I would suggest artillery is still
more important than most other forms of
military unit and certainly most other
forms of gun so just to see that sort of
devastating artillery barrage like that
is really impressive clearly teams of
people having to be used to run these as
well which is which is realistic as well
in terms of the gun itself I think it's
Loosely based on the the famous German
Big Bertha Railway gun or very large
artillery piece which I did which did
come in a I think it was a 30 30.5
centimeter variant this is this is meant
to be 300 ml artillery piece big stuff
like this usually transported and fired
from rails because it's the only way to
get something that's what 42 tons I
think Big Bertha was it's the only way
to get these things around and into any
kind of position where they can fire but
when they do fire you're talking
potentially 10 well tens of miles of
range from from a big artillery piece
well beyond what a normal game map can
possibly handle so all very impressive
foreign
hypnotic flamethrower footage there not
necessarily the most realistic
flamethrowers we've seen I mean they're
they're they're not glaringly wrong or
anything but uh more than anything else
the depiction of the Flaming fuel so
these things projected as I'm sure a lot
of you know thickened flammable liquid
that's not only flammable it is Flaming
and it will stick and burn and it's
pretty horrific there's no evidence here
of this liquid sticking to anything it
doesn't appear to be persistent it does
appear more like an old school video
game flamethrower where you have an area
of effect and as soon as you stop well
the the character might be set on fire
and taking heat damage but but they're
not having the environmental effect that
we would expect from the flamethrower
these are representations of
flamethrowers of the world wars so the
the one with the two tanks on it on a on
a backpack is somewhat reminiscent of
the American M2 and the single tank with
a couple of extra features of interest
on it is more like one of the German
flamenwortha designs that said if I was
playing this I wouldn't want these
things anywhere near me especially not
two of them sort of coordinating
crossing the streams as it were
all right guys thank you very much for
watching as always this is a really
interesting one for me a bit of a
departure from some of the first person
shooters that we've covered to say the
least if you can please do come and
visit us at the Royal armories Museum
here in Leeds in the UK or at the Tower
of London uh we're also present there
and down on the coast at Fort Nelson
where you can see some big guns uh not
Big Bertha but we do in fact have a an
18 inch Railway gun down there that is
very much worth a look otherwise I'll
see you again next time thank you
foreign
[Music]